[Musica]
mi occupo di convergenze e divergenze le
convergenze sono le convergenze di
energie e risorse naturali materie prime
risorse umane all'interno di
organizzazioni economiche che vengono
trasformate e divergono in prodotti se
vi sembra un discorso troppo teorico e
quello che tutti i giorni noi
affrontiamo in qualunque tipo di
attività ma intanto possiamo pensare
agli ingredienti che utilizziamo per
preparare il caffè con la moka abbiamo
del caffè o in grani ho macinato abbiamo
del caffè
abbiamo naturalmente la moka risorse
naturali acqua risorse energetiche tutte
convergono all'interno di un sistema e
troviamo qualcuno che ha della
conoscenza su come combinarle per dar
luogo al caffè una ricetta così semplice
diverge poco perché caffè potrebbe
essere lungo ristretto
se aggiungiamo anche solo pochi
ingredienti ad esempio zucchero ad
esempio latte potremmo avere una
divergenza maggiore perché si scatena la
fantasia e quindi il caffè può essere di
nuovo lungo corto ristretto può essere
macchiato macchiato caldo macchiato
freddo può essere macchiato con latte
scremato o con latte intero e zuccherato
con zucchero normale o zucchero di canna
convergenze e divergenze
ciò che interessa me e del mio gruppo di
ricercatori in particolare sono le
trasformazioni cioè ciò che le
trasformazioni desiderate quindi le
ricette per trasformare materie prime in
prodotti finiti o per erogare servizi e
le trasformazioni indesiderate però
direttamente connesse con le prime cioè
quelle che danno luogo ad impatti
ambientali infatti ambientali come
produzione di rifiuti scarichi decimi
sono in atmosfera emissioni
elettromagnetiche e così via ci
interessano queste tre grandezze questi
tre insiemi di dati perché mettendo in
relazione tra di loro cerchiamo
riusciamo a capire quanto una attività
economica e sostenibile
di vista ambientale economico ma anche
dal punto di vista sociale
abbiamo maturato queste idee in ambienti
apparentemente peculiari in cima a una
montagna
un luogo che è un luogo deputato alla
ricerca per l'università di torino
rifugio regina margherita abbiamo
lavorato nella valle dell'everest della
valle del combo abbiamo lavorato con la
spedizione al k2
abbiamo lavorato in territori collinari
e per ed infine abbiamo lavorato anche
in territori di mare ciò che accomuna
tutti questi territori è l'esistenza di
imprese noi lavoriamo con le
organizzazioni economiche sono più o
meno evidenti ma ci sono ovunque in
questi territori ci sono delle imprese e
noi interessa in particolare interessano
in particolare alle piccole e medie
imprese sono più di 5 milioni di imprese
in italia sono il 92 per cento delle
imprese e quindi se noi riusciamo a
mettere a punto delle ricette per
migliorare le trasformazioni quindi per
ridurre gli impatti ambientali facciamo
diamo un contributo verso la
sostenibilità
i sistemi che noi utilizziamo sono
sistemi che vengono statuiti a livello
internazionale il nostro contributo alla
ricerca è quello di impiegarli in
situazioni anomale per testarne la
robustezza e la flessibilità sono
sistemi che possono essere anche
certificati una volta ideati progettati
implementati e questo grafico dall'idea
di un trend delle idee di un trend di
certificazioni a livello mondiale ea
livello nazionale circa 22 mila gli
ultimi dati sono le imprese certificate
c'è molto spazio per che tra il 22 mila
imprese certificate 5 milioni di piccole
e medie imprese
c'è un grande mercato c'è anche un
grande mercato se noi pensiamo che la
produzione di rifiuti a livello europeo
nel 2017 è stata di 4,5 milioni di
tonnellate 45 miliardi di tonnellate
scusate il 45 per cento è andato in
discariche al 37,2 per cento al
riutilizzo quindi abbiamo ancora spazio
così la stessa cosa vale per quanto
riguarda
le emissioni di co2 equivalenti abbiamo
dunque degli strumenti abbiamo dunque
degli strumenti abbiamo dello spazio
enorme per applicarli qual è il nostro
cruccio il cruccio di chi fa ricerca e
il dato avere a disposizione dati che
siano rappresentativi della realtà
completi di cui si conosca la precisione
è il nostro cruccio e quindi nelle
piccole e medie imprese abbiamo cercato
di sviluppare un'idea che potesse
permetterci di superare questa
difficoltà e cosa si può fare quando si
ha bisogno di dati bisogna amplificare i
propri organi di senso amplificare in
orc organi di senso attraverso dei
sensori e noi siamo circondati da
sensori se voi considerate lo smartphone
che avete in tasca ne ha circa una
decina accelerometro sensore di
luminosità magnetometro al giroscopio
webcam sensore di impronte digitali
sensore di temperatura e via
se pensiamo alle automobili abbiamo da
60 a 100 sensori in un'auto media
se andiamo nelle auto di formula 1
abbiamo un numero che va anche a 300
sensori in un giorno di prove scaricano
qualcosa come 600 gigabyte di dati che
devono essere elaborati ma essenziale
ricordare che l'elemento umano è sempre
importante centro bastoni sensori ma c'è
sempre un elemento umano che deve
riuscire a leggere i dati e poi a
interpretarli in modo adeguato ecco è
necessario disporre dei dati per poter
definire degli obiettivi smart per
definire degli obiettivi che siano
specifici misurabili raggiungibili
realistici e e tempi ti attraverso
i sensori il grande sviluppo che c'è
stato nei sensori sia nell'automobilismo
sia nel negli aeree ad esempio 6.000
sensori distribuiti in un airbus a350
che danno qualche terabyte di dati ogni
giorno in cui l'aereo viaggia ecco sono
un'idea ma altri esempi potrebbero
essere le cosiddette smart city
l'osservatorio dell'anci ci parla di un
48 per cento dei comuni italiani
non è che ha avviato delle iniziative di
smart izzazione che hanno riguardato la
illuminazione l'ottimizzazione
dell'illuminazione la il controllo dei
rifiuti la sicurezza e la logistica
quindi ci sono degli degli ambiti in cui
i sensori vengono applicati i sensori da
soli fanno già molto perché questa
enorme applicazione che c'è stata
abbassata considerevolmente i prezzi e
quindi troviamo sensori che sono utili
per monitorare tutte le variabili
ambientali associate a dei processi di
trasformazione quindi qualità dell'aria
qualità dell'acqua energia elettrica
consumati temperature umidità luminosità
troviamo sensori adatti per
l'agricoltura tant'è che oggi si parla
di agricoltura di precisione
questa onda di sensori ampiamente
disponibile a basso costo non avrebbe
potuto esprimere la sua potenzialità
se non ci fossero stati due momenti che
si riferiscono anche a due grandi
sistemi in cui avviene della
sperimentazione 1 del 2005 con
l'invenzione del microcontrollore
arduino questo tipo di sensore ad
esempio serve per sviluppare degli
oggetti come quelli che vedete sulla mia
testa che rilevano il battito cardiaco e
a seconda dell'intensità del battito
cardiaco fanno un gioco di luci o
un'intensità luminosa physical computing
l'altro aspetto interessante di questa
diapositiva e che nel tempo la grande
applicazione che c'è stata di questi
oggetti ha portato a rendere disponibili
in grandi quantità per rispondere a
domande specifiche e le domande
specifiche erano rivolte a passare dal
singolo oggetto alla costruzione di reti
di oggetti e quindi si è passati da
oggetti dalle prime schede con poche
ingressi ed uscite convergere e
divergere quindi gli ingressi di sensori
di uscite di altri dispositivi a schede
molto più performanti anche in termini
di distanza di comunicazione quindi si è
passati dalla singola unita alla
creazione di una rete
ma sempre una rete locale un altro forte
impulso è stato dato dalla raspberry
foundation attorno 2008 2009
il primo era un microcontrollore questo
microcomputer vero e proprio l'obiettivo
di questa fondazione è quello di
favorire l'apprendimento
dell'informatica partire dalle scuole
primarie attraverso ambienti giocosi
attraverso esperimenti attraverso una
sperimentazione che coinvolge il mondo
abbiamo dunque sensori microcontrollori
sistemi per agevolare la trasmissione
dati anche degli attuatori c'è in
relazione dell'intensità dei segnali
attraverso sei semplici attuatori che
potrebbero essere servomotori piuttosto
che pompi piuttosto che display eccetera
accade qualcosa sulla base della ricetta
che è stata insegnata al
microcontrollore cioè al software e
quindi siamo in grado di realizzare il
famoso sistema nervoso possiamo
distribuire in un'organizzazione
economica i sensori che servono per
monitorare gli impatti specifici che
derivano da quell organizzazione
economica per mettere in relazione gli
impatti con gli elementi in ingresso e
gli elementi in uscita
dell'organizzazione economica quando
queste reti o quando questi oggetti che
ne abbiamo chiamato scatolotti perché in
modo confidenziale ci si rivolge a
questi oggetti di cui non si sa bene che
cosa faccia ma sono amichevoli ci
ritroviamo in casa ci rivolgiamo
lì ci indirizziamo con il termine
scatolotto quando questi scatolotti
hanno un indirizzo unico sull'in su
internet vengono direttamente in modo
univoco identificati su internet si
forma l'internet degli oggetti e
l'internet degli oggetti è un fenomeno
in grande espansione e un fenomeno che
in italia vale circa 5 miliardi di euro
a livello mondiale si stima che nel 2022
sia di 561 miliardi di euro il mercato
di questi oggetti la diffusione di
questi oggetti e gioca interessante chi
agevola la diffusione soprattutto la
produzione di soluzioni innovative
orientate a risolvere dei problemi e che
la sperimentazione è cambiata c'è un
nuovo empirismo
quando io ho iniziato a programmare i
computer che nei primi anni ottanta
c'era questa tavoletta che veniva
chiamata a tavoletta di cioccolato zx
spectrum un computer che costava allora
più o meno come un motorino
adesso le schede costano da 20 a 50 euro
tanto per dare l'idea dell'accessibilità
economica l'altro aspetto è la narrativa
sullo sviluppo dell'informatica ci parla
di individui o amici che all'interno di
laboratori garage hanno sviluppato dei
progetti che hanno cambiato il mondo in
questo caso c'è una il nuovo empirismo è
a delle nuove regole queste nuove regole
sono c'è una collaborazione cioè la
community a livello mondiale che
alimenta la rete internet con dei
problemi e c'è la community che
collabora per la soluzione di questi
problemi
quindi si va verso delle soluzioni
entrambe arduino era smerillo sono
cosiddette e l'accesso libero open
source allora parliamo di convergenze di
emergenza e quando è venuto in mente di
provare a sviluppare una teoria noi
vediamo in modo del tutto quello
qualitativo che nel tempo sono aumentate
le certificazioni ambientali o comunque
l'introduzione di sistemi di gestione
ambientale nell'impresa e così come
abbiamo un andamento esponenziale per
quanto riguarda l'internet degli oggetti
potremmo immaginare una cosa del genere
nel 2011 abbiamo cominciato a realizzare
i nostri scatolotti per risolvere il
problema della mancanza di dati e quindi
unite un intersecazione c'è stata
potremmo immaginare che si apra di lì in
avanti uno spazio nel quale li nella
zona tratteggiata potrebbe capire
capitare qualcosa di questo genere cioè
l'incrocio faccia in modo che ci sia un
un effetto sinergico cioè che ci sia un
incremento delle applicazioni dei
sistemi di gestione che permettono di
controllare di rendere le imprese più
eco efficienti nell'ambito del paradigma
dell'economia circolare grazie al fatto
che possono essere sviluppate dei
sistemi
aiuti orientati proprio questo scopo
quindi la nostra attività è riuscito a
decollare grazie con i miei
collaboratori grazie ad un progetto
della regione piemonte dove abbiamo
messo a punto queste reti in quello che
il nostro ambiente di gioco il nostro
luogo normale che è che la montagna e
quindi abbiamo realizzato dei prototipi
di reti in alcuni rifugi nel momento in
cui i dati vengono rilevati la prima
attività che viene compiuta la
visualizzazione dei dati attraverso dei
cruscotti personalizzati i cruscotti
riportano l'andamento istantaneo delle
variabili all'interno di un range
soprattutto man mano che i dati vengono
visualizzati questi dati vengono anche
ad alimenti vanno anche ad alimentare
delle banche dati e quindi abbiamo la
possibilità di studiare i dati ed
elaborare dei modelli previsionali
altro aspetto interessante dell'internet
degli oggetti che quando i dati vengono
riversati su internet ci si trova sempre
su internet
altri dati ad accesso libero che hanno
messo a disposizione altri gruppi di
ricerca o altri soggetti e dunque
scegliendo opportunamente i dati può
essere possibile migliorare e
ottimizzare dei modelli previsionali
incrociando con metodi statistici
opportuni le diverse rilevazioni abbiamo
sviluppato un'esperienza abbastanza
lunga molto divertente incoraggiante in
tema di educazione ambientale coinvolge
coinvolgendo alunni fin dalle scuole
primarie nella progettazione degli abiti
dei nostri scatolotti lo scatolotto deve
essere modulare perché può essere tanto
ad accesso libero
usiamo e riversiamo le ricette che
scriviamo in cui nostri codici modulare
può essere configurato a seconda delle
necessità che si manifestano nelle
diverse attività economiche e
soprattutto l'abito di scatolotto deve
comunicare la sostenibilità come può
essere utile il dato rispetto alla
definizione degli obiettivi in aziende
al monitoraggio del dell'andamento delle
variabili e la verifica rispetto al
raggiungimento degli obiettivi i dati
possono essere confrontati con gli
obiettivi
e quindi in tempo reale sia l'idea della
distanza tra il dato effettivo il dato
reale è l'obiettivo
ecco ciò che è capitato e che ci ha
incoraggiato e dell'ultimo progetto di
cui vi parlo è il tema della dei
dispositivi indossabili perché i
dispositivi indossabili permettono di
realizzare quello che noi vorremmo fare
delle reti umane cioè gli umani gli
indossatori gli oggetti come questi che
derivano da un'app cycling di denim
usato possono hanno delle strisce di led
che fanno un effetto scenico c'è posso
cambiare il colore in relazione al mood
posso ad esempio così però vedete una
striscia scusate le spalle ma c'è una
striscia che cambia di colore e cambio
di colore in relazione all'intensità
della variabile monitorata la variabile
monitorata in questo caso è la
luminosità e sotto questi riflettori e
dell 83 per cento all'ora l'aspetto
interessante che gli umani diventano
nodi di una rete
questa rete manda i dati ad un server
vanno su internet ben vengano
geolocalizzati e quindi si può avere
delle mappe di qualità ambientale ecco
questo è in grande il nostro la nostra
app allora per concludere direi che la
grande diffusione delle reti le
potenzialità che permette l'internet
degli oggetti fanno sì che se prima ho
parlato di una carenza di dati
oggi ci possa essere un diluvio di dati
abbiamo necessità di accumulare dati ma
anche di sapere come utilizzarli e
allora per far questo ci sono degli
elementi strutturali che devono essere
risolti per usare davvero bene la grande
abbondanza di dati e la possibilità che
dall'internet un elemento strutturale e
il digital divide
ma questo non dipende da noi invece può
dipendere da noi maggiormente il tema
della security dei dati allora ho
concluso quando le domande perché me le
pongo tutti i giorni cioè quanto il
nostro sistema la nostra scuola di
management
in particolare è sensibile alla
alfabetizzazione nel campo
dell'informatica
quindi io troverei una convergenza
molto utile tra il sapere di base delle
diverse corsi universitari verso una
alfabetizzazione informatica che
riguardi sia l'hardware che il software
di in modo tale che poi con le proprie
conoscenze si dia sostanza quella che si
chiama di l'era dell'intensificazione
della creatività divergendo trovando
delle applicazioni nuove
vi ringrazio